Speaker 1: Okay, let's do Friday feedback.
And many of you wrote to me and said, David,
what is Friday feedback going to be like this
week after what happened last week and going
through the hate mob that came after you? Well,
I'm not going to make this all negative. There
were tens of thousands, if not hundreds
of thousands of disgusting hate messages,
including many anti-Semitic. But what I do want
to tell you is that there is a movement that is
insisting there were no such hate messages. There
were no anti-Semitic messages or anything. And you
can sometimes see them quite literally next to
anti-Semitic messages. For example, user shein
used the anti-Semitic meme 6 million, which of
course, relates to the 6 million Jews killed in
the Holocaust. And they love to reference like
should have been more or whatever, 6 million.
So this is another one of these anti-Semitic
messages next to a message that says there's not
a hate mob after you. There are just thousands
of individual people that heard your comments
and found them disgusting. Really? And why does
that then necessitate making horrible comments
about the Holocaust? It's sort of difficult to
understand, but many other fascinating messages
on the substance of preventing mass shootings and
reducing gun violence. We got a great comment on
YouTube, which reads, David, as a veteran of law
enforcement, myself and gun owning individual
while also being a Christian father of two. Don't
let Republicans drag you down the rabbit hole.
They intend you to do so when engaging you. Your
list of ten is, quite honestly very good. These
are ten policies to reduce gun violence I laid
out. What I would add is specifically a sliding
scale fee and structure that low income Americans
do not get financially discriminated against when
following the list of ten are. So this might be
the training a scales for the cost of training
and licensing scales for income. I think I get the
idea and a very interesting idea for sure. Henman
left the message and says, David, I'm a rock
solid centrist with not much of an appreciation
for left or right. But you are one of the very few
leftist commentators I watch consistently because
of your balanced, calm, collected demeanor when
tackling subjects hold fast against the fascist
hordes of Republicans and their extended members.
We're behind you all the way to defend your free
speech. Not right wing defined free speech.
I mean freedom of speech in the traditional
sense of the word. Before it was hijacked by the
right. All the best. With much love for the UK.
Thank you. And lots of Brits, by the way, weighing
in recently, which I very, very much appreciate.
Cheryl said by going after you. They move
the target off of them for doing absolutely
nothing to stop this horrible epidemic that only
happens in our country. Bless you, David. I'm so
sorry you're having to go through this. Yeah. You
know, there must not be anything we can do to stop
the scourge of gun violence. Say, people in the
only country where this is regularly happening.
Are we really that willing to give up without
trying almost anything? It's really pathetic.
On the issue of thoughts and prayers. Very
interesting comment. The congressional this is
Riley. The congressional chaplain said it was time
for more than thoughts and prayers. Does he get
threatened? You're in the right. David. Yeah. And
in fact, you know, what's been really interesting
since the blow up last week is that all sorts of
other the prayers aren't enough. Did they not pray
correctly or hard enough sort of stuff? Dozens, at
least, of relatively prominent people made similar
statements. There was one in the Boston Globe and
others. None of them generated any controversy.
Any controversy. Okay. Then we're moving on to
some other issues. Jason commented on Facebook.
Speaker 2: David underwear.
Speaker 1: Pacman. I don't even know what
that means. Instead of reviewing polls, maybe you
should look at the actual statistics of illegal
immigrants crossing the border. Why do they always
put the wrong border? Border like a boarding house
rather than the US-Mexico border? Jason says it's
in the millions and the highest ever because of
Biden's policies. How can you even try to defend
this topic? There is no border again, wrong border
boa RDR, but merely a fading line in the sand.
Remember a couple of things on that. Number one,
they are stopping people from coming in over the
border is clearly open because of all the people
that Border Patrol is stopping. Wait, so it must
be closed then because they're stopping people.
That's number one. Number two, we know a lot
about the surge of attempts under Joe Biden. It
started to increase under Trump. As COVID waned,
mobility resumed and people started again trying
to come over the border in greater numbers.
They act like we don't know that there are
simple explanations for most of these things.
Let's now go to the subreddit. L. Deuce t.
Wrote Marjorie Taylor GREENE says we need more
good guys with guns. I think she's right. But how
do you become a good guy with a gun? Introducing
the good guy with a gun certificate. Pass the
mental assessment. Pass the background check.
Pass the gun safety course. Congratulations.
You're now a certified good guy with a
gun now. Of course I would go further.
You get yourself the required, like the
liability insurance that should be required
in order to have firearms. You are regularly
retested and undergo regular psych eval. You
are limited in terms of high capacity magazines
based on your age. It's quite an extensive list,
but certainly we are nowhere near that at this
point in time. Continuing to talk about firearms,
this is this is an interesting message question
from a non-American. Why are Americans so obsessed
with guns? Why do you need them? And why are
some of you against restrictions? Some people
don't even acknowledge the problem. I mean,
what do you expect? There have been more mass
shootings than days in 2023. So what can be done?
Arm teachers, as was proposed, blame things that
have nothing to do with it transpeople, video
games, porn, etc. or ban on some kind of weapons
like assault weapons. Yeah. This you know, this
person got downvoted down into a hole in the
ground, but they're absolutely right. And it's
interesting. There are right wing pro-gun people
who bristle at the idea that sissy Europeans might
tell us what to do with guns. Well, we should look
at it a different way. We should say.
Speaker 2: People.
Speaker 1: From countries that don't have this
epidemic of gun violence are shocked and horrified
by what's happening in the United States. Maybe
we should consider whether they have something
to offer. And this is part of the problem. You
know, when I was on the PBD program, Patrick Bet,
David's podcast that I explained under Trump,
global opinion of the US end of the presidency
was in the toilet. And their response, when
they can no longer deny the facts, is to say,
Why do we care what other countries think of
us? If other countries don't like us, if other
countries are scared of us, that means we're doing
the best possible thing we can for Americans.
And of course, that's obviously not the case in
insofar as we live in a globalized world. We're
not this isolated country. We're not an island
economically and literally. We're not an island.
We actually do depend on other countries for so
many things. And so this idea of what do we care
what they think? It's predominantly an idea on
the right and it's extraordinarily short sighted.
And unfortunately, that's the issue, right? Oh, my
God. Look, someone someone from a country that has
no gun violence has the audacity to say, what the
hell is wrong with you people in the U.S.? Yeah,
that should really make you think, Oh, wow.
You mean this is optional? It doesn't have to
be like this. Give me a break, guys. All right.
And then more superficially, there was a poll
done on our subreddit. What's your favorite
nickname for Ron DeSantis? The options were
Ron to sanctimonious tiny D meatball, Ron Gay.
Ron, which I don't even understand. Deep State,
Ron or something else. Overwhelmingly, our Reddit
audience prefers Meatball Ron as the name for Ron
DeSantis. I have to tell you, I don't really
love it. I don't really love it. And I know
that Ron to sanctimonious is a problem because
many Republicans wouldn't know how to spell
sanctimonious nor what it means. So that one's
problematic. I still like wrong. Death Santas.
Wrong. Death Santas. But it's a little tough
to say. Open to ideas. This guy may not even
end up running. So let's wait and see before
we subject him to a permanent nickname. All
right. Keep those messages coming. You can email
info at David Pakman dot com. You might post to
the subreddit and it could end up on Friday.
Feedback. You might make a comment on YouTube
or send a tweet or God forbid, make a Facebook
comment. Any of these things could end up with
you in Friday. Feedback. We have a tremendous
bonus show for you today. I will be away the next
few days and be back with you next Friday. We will
have a mix of guest hosts, including producer Pat
and others. I think people will like it. If you
hate all of the guest hosts, you'll be furious.
If you like one of the guest hosts, hopefully
there will be a little something for everyone
next week. All right, everybody. So I'll see you
then. On to the bonus show. Onward and upward.